why did Daniel fal's husband become
internet famous for shrimp tailes and
what's the game show she hosted that you
definitely don't remember after Boy
Meets World fal's career was never the
same in the mid1 1990s one of the
biggest sitcoms around was Boy Meets
World though the show focused on the
life of Cory Matthews the most enduring
character for a lot of fans is his love
interest fal's to panga Fel made the
role her own and created one of the most
memorable Network TV characters of the
era so when boy meet's world came to an
end in 2000 Danielle fishell was
definitely writing High she appeared on
a few magazine covers and seemed poised
to become the next rising star in
Hollywood it was pretty surprising then
when her next career step took the form
of starring in National Lampoon's dorm
days which holds the honor of having
zero positive critic reviews on Rotten
Tomatoes dorm days was part of a slew of
2000s films that coasted on the National
Lampoon brand recognition most of which
boasted a tiny budget and banked on
runchy humor FAL would go on to reprise
her role in the direct to DVD sequel one
of the reasons tapanga is such a beloved
character is the Breezy self-assured
attitude that fishell brought to the
role shoots
ow while major acting roles didn't seem
to come her way after Boy Meets World
that vibrant personality officials still
showed up on Plenty of TV sets as a host
fishal eventually became the co-host of
the MTV game show say what karaoke for
its final season alongside the real
world contestant Steven Hill she also
showed off her comedic delivery as the
host of style net works the dish a
sister show to the eer the soup the dish
was actually a pretty good stepping
stone for fishal as it provided her with
Pathways into other hosting gigs over
the years Daniel FAL showcased her
hosting abilities on a number of
traditional TV talk shows in the 2000s
but she also took on a more modern
hosting gig in 2013 she became the face
of a pop sugar YouTube series called
dear Danielle where she provided advice
on sex dating and love for the Channel's
audience some of the episodes are
standard advice Style videos were
officially addressed a specific question
or comment from a user others delve more
into skit territory like her how to spot
a cheater episode ultimately dear
Danielle didn't last possibly because of
its odd pairing of nostalgia and Target
demographic a good portion of Pop
Sugar's teenage audience in the early
2010s would have been too young to
remember boy's World from its late '90s
Heyday and might not have recognized
tapanga Nostalgia is the gift that keeps
on giving seemingly any movie or show
that's remembered fondly is ripe for a
reboot sequel prequel or reimagining in
2014 fans of Boy Meets World got a
sequel relaunch hybrid a show that
features several members of the original
cast reprising their roles and
storylines from the original series and
just like that with Girl Meets World
tapena was back on TV Girl Meets World
premiered on the Disney Channel in June
2014 it focuses on Riley Matthews the
teenage daughter of tapena and Corey as
she navigates school and relationships
along with all the drama that comes with
those things okay what's going on with
her I don't know don't do anything
both fishell and Ben Savage returned to
their roles from Boy Meets World hitting
the Nostalgia buttons for a number of
parents who sat down to watch the new
series with their kids girl meat's world
didn't just Coast on that Nostalgia
aspect though it had a positive critical
reception and was able to successfully
bring some of the spirit of the original
show into a new era after three seasons
girl meet's world came to an end but
Creator Michael Jacobs searched to find
a new home for the story to continue it
seems unlikely at this point but never
say never maybe we'll see Topanga's
grandkids navigate the Halls of high
school sometime down the line fal's easy
communicating style lends itself
perfectly to a memoir in 2014 she made
that happen when she released normally
this would be caused for concern Tales
of Calamity and unrelenting awkwardness
in her Memoir Fel definitely dishes some
stories of her time on boy meat's World
and Other acting roles but it isn't a
juicy tell all story of tabloid fodder
instead Fel uses her experiences to
express certain themes she seems to
Relish in her imperfections and
certainly has no issues with sharing
some of her most embarrassing stories
one of her memorable stories revolves
around a Halloween party Fishel wore
very tall heels and wound up tripping
she remembers being helped up by a
terrifyingly handsome giant who turned
out to be Ben afflac at the time she was
more worried about bleeding on the star
than about her injuries it's a fun
Breezy read if you enjoy Memoirs if you
want tons of behind the-scenes stories
about boy meet's World Daniel fishell
and some of her fellow castmates have
just the solution for you fishell along
with her former co-star writer strong
and will fidell began a rewatch podcast
in 2022 called pod Meets World as a
rewatch podcast episodes of pod Meets
World tend to focus on specific episodes
about which the hosts share stories and
memories this moment kind of made me
tear up it's a pretty fun listen the
cast of Boy Meets World were of course
just kids when the show began and the
podcast often talks about what it was
like to grow up right in front of the
audience in addition to FAL strong and
Fidel other actors and crew members from
the series make appearances to talk
about their roles and what they remember
of filming such a well-loved series they
even invite super fans of the show to
talk about what Boy Meets World meant to
them like most officials work pod Meets
World is a fun and easy listen even if
you aren't a huge fan of Boy Meets World
it's tough to not crack a smile hearing
the trio reminisce though Fel has made
quite a name for herself as approachable
and self-deprecating she's also shared a
few pretty scary stories of her time on
boy me's World Fel has often shared
stories about her struggles with her
body image often due to societal
pressures and comments from her Show's
audience she says that boy meet's world
was an especially difficult time for her
she told people that when she was 16 she
weighed 89 lb took laxatives and would
sometimes eat only iceberg lettuce for
her meals she actually collapsed on set
one day eventually she realized that her
health was more important than forcing
her body to adhere to Impossible
standards unfortunately we live in a
society where they tell us we have to
look a certain way an even worse story
involves some fan mail she got as a
young actress when Fel first started on
the show she received a letter from a
girl her age who was a fan she began
writing back and forth with the girl who
turned out not to exist fal's mother
eventually figured out that she was
being catfished by a grown man the
incident gave her and her co-stars a
chance to talk about setting boundaries
between actors and their fans
considering fishel's lifelong experience
working in the sitcom environment it
should come as no surprise that she has
found herself in the director's chair on
occasion she seems to be a go-to
director for several Disney sitcoms
which makes perfect sense considering
ing she can address some of the flaws
she experienced during her Boy Meets
World run her first directorial
experience came in 2016 for an episode
of Girl Meets World she directed four
episodes total and has also sat in the
director's chair for several Disney
series since then in March 2023 Fel got
the chance to direct her first non-
Disney show an episode of the NBC series
Lopez versus Lopez considering how many
credits she's racked up in such a short
time it wouldn't be surprising to see
fishel's name on the credits of more
sitcoms moving forward Fel hasn't
publicly dated all that many people over
the years but she has been married twice
in October 2013 she tied the nut with
Tim bco a student at California State
University whom she'd been dating for
several years they kept their
relationship private and ultimately
divorced just as quietly in 2016 however
her new single life didn't last long in
March 2018 she got engaged to Jensen
karp a writer and producer they walked
down the aisle later that year and had
two sons together as an interesting
footnote in this romance there's another
reason you may know the name Jensen car
aside from his position as toa's husband
in 2021 karp went somewhat viral when he
claimed to have found dried shrimp tails
in a box of Cinnamon Toast Crunch he
tweeted a photo of the crustacean
contamination which caught the attention
of General Mills the company that makes
the cereal I went to Twitter and was
like Hey guys why is there shrimp tails
in my cereal there was plenty of back
and forth with their social media
accounts as General Mills claimed there
was no way the incident could have
occurred at their facility and asked
carp to send in the box so they could
investigate was it a a prank or a
serious case of sullied cereal
unfortunately any chance of answering
that mystery seems to have died with
carp's X account so we'll probably never
know on the bright side carp and Fel
appeared to have a thriving
relationship despite the Monumental
success of boy meet's world and the
positive reception to Girl Meets World
Fel has been in surprisingly few
projects over the past few decades Fel
hasn't had much luck on the movie side
of things sandwiched between the dorm
days films was a straight to DVD sci-fi
film called gamebox 1.0 she also starred
in the similarly unknown 2015 film
Boiling Pot she had a role in the
bizarre short film clapping for the
wrong reasons starring and written by
Donald Glover and she voiced a character
in a 2007 Indie animated film called The
Chosen One in fact one of the main
reasons you don't see Fishel much on TV
lately is because most of her television
work has been on the voice over front
she voiced ponica on a few episodes of
the much loved series Gravity Falls and
she also voiced a librarian on Star
versus the forces of evil okay you're
all set dear oh and could you tell your
mother hello for me with a family to
care for and a popular podcast series
it's no big surprise that Fel hasn't
start in a lot lately but here's hoping
she'll make the return to the screen
sometime
[Music]
soon